لا يخفى على أحد أن النوم
مرتبط ارتباطًا وثيقًا بالصحة العامة للفرد ، ولكن
وجدت دراسة جديدة أن الأشخاص الذين يأخذون قيلولة
بانتظام لديهم فرصة أكبر
لتطوير مخاطر صحية ، استخدمت الدراسة
بيانات من 360 ألف شخص ووجدت
أن المشاركين الذين أخذوا قيلولة
أثناء النهار كانوا 12 عامًا.  في المائة أكثر
عرضة للإصابة بارتفاع ضغط الدم
بمرور الوقت ، وكانوا أكثر
عرضة للإصابة بسكتة دماغية بنسبة 24 في المائة مقارنة
بالأشخاص الذين لم يغفو مطلقًا ، لماذا قد
تكون القيلولة مرتبطة بالسكتة الدماغية وهل هو
سبب حقيقي أم عرض
لشيء آخر د. كريستين كنودسن  يقول
أستاذ مشارك في علم الأعصاب
والطب الوقائي في الجامعة الشمالية الغربية
إن أخذ قيلولة ليس
ضارًا ، لكن القيام بذلك في كثير من الأحيان قد يكون
مؤشرًا على الظروف الصحية الأساسية
إذا كنت تشعر
بالنعاس حقًا أثناء النهار في كثير من الأوقات
يجب أن تتحدث مع  يحاول الطبيب
فهم سبب
عدم شعورك بالراحة بعد ليلة من
النوم والمساعدة في الحصول على ليلة مريحة.
يقول الدكتور إيب دكتور كنوتسون ، جرب ما يلي
إبقاء غرفة نومك هادئة
وباردة وليست ساخنة جدًا في محاولة للحفاظ على
وقت نوم منتظم وتجنب الكافيين في فترة ما
بعد الظهر وتجنب الضوء الساطع
بما في ذلك عدم توجيه الهواتف الذكية الخاصة
بك قبل الذهاب إلى السرير مباشرة ، لن
أتخلص من القيلولة تمامًا
هناك الكثير من الثقافات التي تأخذ قيلولة
كجزء من نمطها اليومي المعتاد ، لذلك
نحتاج إلى فهم أنواع
القيلولة وأسبابها قبل أن نشعر
بالذعر ونعتقد أن جميع القيلولة ضارة بالصحة.